I never forget
asking a doctor,
oh,
he and I have a novelist once.
Ed,
what do you think a new row c says?
An Eddie said,
it's the endless repetition of an
obsolete experience are failing.
And the trouble with age drives we get
as children
is there often
come about
for some emotional reason,
having to do okay with gang gaining our
parents love or respect or something.
And uh,
because it's not the real thing.
The real thing is just to be
spontaneously love,
not to have to go through this enormous
process.
It,
it's air sacs.
It's artificial.
Okay.
And You keep repeating it and repeating
it,
repeating it because it isn't real
somehow.
So I think that's true in life.
I think sometimes,
okay,
when you develop they just neurotic
pattern Jew.
Okay.
You keep repeating these earlier
patterns,
uh,
often too.
Either no end at all or to an end that
has very little to do with the,
and you're really after,
right?
So I think it's important.
We're all strangers to our unconscious
to,
um,
try to go back and understand.
I'm not sure what we're doing.
Yeah.
Started decades and decades to go.
For reasons or motivations that have
very little to do with today and how
much of that is relevant and how much is
excessive.
Okay.